A GOOGLE CRISIS:
The
date is July of 2001.
Out of the blue, Larry Page, co-founder and
CEO of Google, sends a cryptic email summoning
all Google engineers and project managers
to meet outside his office to share some unexpected
news.
Within a matter of minutes, all 130 of Google’s
engineers and project managers would form
a huddle around Page’s office anxious what
the news could be.
Did Google get sued by Yahoo?
Was AOL threatening a hostile takeover?
Was the company about to run out of funding?
As these thoughts raced through engineers
minds, Page candidly stepped out of his office.
And with his usual horse voice, he would firmly
announce that all project managers were fired
effective immediately.
All engineers were to report to some newly
hired engineer named Wayne Rosing.
Everyone was stunned.
This wasn’t about the state of Google or
the future of the company.
This was about Page’s personal hatred for
managers.
You see, Page strongly felt that Google had
hired the best engineers in the world and
that these brilliant individuals didn’t
need untechnical morons telling them what
to do.
He felt that engineers should be able to choose
what they work and set their own paces, and
he was hoping that Google’s engineers would
agree.
But, to his surprise, it was actually the
engineers that would speak back.
One engineer named Ron Dolin snapped back
that what Page was doing was “completely
ridiculous” and “totally unprofessional”.
Page as gobsmacked.
Surely, other engineers would understand the
freedom of having no managers and support
the purge.
Maybe, they just needed a bit of time to adjust,
so Page woud adjourn the meeting and hoped
things would settle down, but they didn’t.
Within just a few weeks, projects would start
lacking resources, redundancy would fall off
a cliff, and engineers were craving 1 on 1
feedback from a direct superior.
Unsurprisingly, VC funders were pissed, and
it didn’t take long for HR to step in.
They would reinstate all of Google’s fired
project managers and before you knew it, there
was someone new on the chopping block: co
founder Larry Page.
A man named Eric Schmidt was to become the
new CEO and Chairman of Google and Larry Page
would be relieved of all duties.
Instead, he was to take on a more advisory
role behind Eric.
Page was devastated, he had just been Steve
Jobsed, kicked out of his own company and
basically given a pity role as an advisor.
But, looking back, this was for the best as
Eric Schmidt would take Google from being
a brilliant startup to being a tech empire.
He would lead the company for the next 10
years and make Google the leader in email,
video sharing, search, maps, cloud, browsers,
mobile, and more.
He would grow a fortune of $25 billion for
himself as he spearheaded Google into becoming
a multi hundred billion dollar company.
But, almost as magically as he appeared at
Google, he would vanish as this is the story
of the forgotten CEO that saved Google from
its own founder: Eric Schmidt.
THE WHITE KNIGHT:
While Eric was an outsider, he was by no means
unqualified.
Eric was born in Falls Church, Virginia on
April 27, 1955 to two academics.
His mother Eleanor had a masters in psychology
way back in the 1950s and his father was an
extremely well respected economics professor.
He not only taught at Virginia Tech and John
Hopkins University, but he would go on to
serve in the US Treasury under President Richard
Nixon.
Little to say, Eric had a pretty strong background
which allowed him to excel at school and attend
Princeton University.
There he would receive a bachelors in electrical
engineering in 1976 before moving onto UC
Berkeley to get a masters.
Eric got a masters in Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science in 1979, but it seems
that one of his graduate school projects was
even more valuable than the education itself.
You see, Eric would design and implement a
network called Berknet that linked up the
computer centers of two departments, the CS
department and the EECS department.
This project would actually evolve into becoming
a PhD thesis about managing distributed software
development.
And Eric would cash in on this PhD in 1982
also from the UC Berkeley.
During his academic years, he would jump around
a bunch of IT companies from Bell Labs to
Xerox’s famous Palo Alto Research Center.
But, his real career in tech didn’t start
till 1983 when he joined Sun Microsystems
as their first software manager.
This is quite ironic as this was the exact
position that Larry Page would try to eliminate
at Google 20 years later, but let’s just
say that Eric would more than prove that this
position was more than just a placeholder
at Sun.
Eric would rise up the ranks like a madman
first being promoted to director of software
engineering before being promoted to vice
president of software products and then vice
president of general systems.
Eric followed this up with a promotion to
president and finally a promotion to Chief
Technological Officer.
During his 14 years at Sun, Eric oversaw the
creation of one of the most respected tech
empires of the 1990s.
Now of course, Sun would get crushed by the
dotcom crash and be completely forgotten about,
but that’s a wholenother story.
I guess you could say that it’s a good thing
that Eric left at the top in 1997 and took
on a position as CEO and Chairman of Novell.
If you’re not familiar with Novell, they
were actually the second largest producer
of software at one point, only beaten out
by Microsoft.
But, by the late 90s, they were a declining
giant, and Eric was brought in to turn around
the company.
He would oversee a major transition in network
technology from IPX to TCP while trying to
fend of Microsoft.
It seems that he was actually pretty successful
as the company was in a good enough position
to acquire some beaten down dotcom companies
like Cambridge Technology Partners.
But, Eric wasn’t able to get much further
than that as right after this acquisition,
he would be called into babysit Larry Page
and Sergey Brin.
A SAVIOR STEPS IN:
Like Steve Jobs, Larry Page and Sergey Brin
were actually able to choose who would take
on the position of CEO, and it was them who
chose Eric.
Thankfully for Google, Eric wasn’t another
John Sculley.
While Google’s board and investors did pressure
Eric to reign in Larry and Sergey, Eric didn’t
give into this pressure.
You see, though Eric was hired to be a babysitter,
he felt that it was much more suitable for
him to take on the role of personal assistant.
While Eric was exceptionally qualified, probably
even more qualified than Larry and Sergey
at the time, he recognized that it was not
his place to inject his own vision for the
company.
At the end of the day, this was Larry and
Sergey’s company and he was simply hired
to help them execute their vision without
pissing off the board or investors, and that’s
exactly what he did.
After he took over, he would give Larry and
Sergey full freedom to continue leading the
company from a technical and visionary standpoint.
Eric would simply take care of all of the
daily nuances and obstacles that came along
with running and scaling a startup.
Things like addressing investors, addressing
the board, handling public relations, dealing
with HR, scaling the worforce, resolving conflicts,
and launching products on time and on budget.
Basically, all of the boring stuff that comes
along with being CEO.
But, while boring, this is the lifeblood of
any company and especially an up and coming
startup like Google.
Also, if you have any doubts about just how
much freedom Eric gave Larry and Sergey, here’s
how many acquisitions went down at Google.
Larry and Sergey would find something that
interested them, they would buy the company,
and Eric would find out after everything was
said and done.
This is actually how Google ended up with
Android and Google Maps.
A regular CEO would probably be quite bothered
by this, but Eric figured that Larry and Sergey
were the most incentivized to not ruin the
company.
Aside from giving Larry and Sergey space,
Eric also formed key relationships with other
tech companies.
For example, in late 2006, he would join Apple’s
board of directors right before the launch
of the iPhone.
But, despite all this freedom, for the first
few years, Larry always had a level of distrust
with Eric.
I mean after all, Eric was literally hired
to replace Larry.
But, overtime, Larry would grow comfortable
with delegating basically everything to Eric
other than the vision.
A great example of this was Larry’s waning
meeting attendance.
Larry was never a fan of meetings, but he
was intent on attending them in the early
days as he wanted to make sure that Eric didn’t
overrule his voice.
But, by 2007, he would stop attending meetings
altogether as he trusted that Eric would carry
out what he wanted.
By 2008, Larry would also stop doing interviews
altogether stating that that was what Eric
was for.
Larry and Eric were getting along better than
the board could have ever imagined, but this
golden period didn’t last forever at Google.
THE FALLOUT:
As Larry and Sergey got to know Eric better,
they realized that while he was exceptional
at execution, he wasn’t a risk taker.
Sure, he was willing to let Larry and Sergey
mess around with acquisitions and run crazy
April Fools day pranks with Gmail and YouTube.
But when it came to something that could truly
threaten the company, Eric would always choose
the conservative way out and one of the best
examples of this was with Chrome.
Chrome was pretty late to the browser scene
having not been released till late 2008.
But, this wasn’t because Chrome was an afterthought.
It was because Eric wouldn’t allow for Chrome.
Larry and Sergey had actually pitched Chrome
to Eric for 6 full years, but he always rejected
the idea stating that the space was simply
too monopolized and saturated.
It wasn’t until Larry and Sergey went behind
Eric’s back and secretly developed a Chrome
prototype that Eric simply gave up on trying
to stop them.
Now of course, Chrome would go on to be a
roaring success, so this was definitely something
that Eric got wrong, but it’s not what pushed
him out.
What pushed him out was his stance on China.
As you know, the CCP is the CCP, and you either
play by their rules or you get out.
Throughout the early 2000s, Eric had worked
painstakingly hard to play by the CCP’s
rules and get Google launched in China in
2006.
But, by the late 2000s, China was changing
up the rules and they wanted Google to censor
certain topics.
While not ideal, Eric was more than happy
to do this.
After all, he felt that it was more important
for Google to stay relevant in what he describes
as the world’s largest consumer marketplace.
Larry and Sergey, however, disagreed.
They felt that it was more important for Google
to stick by their motto of “Don’t be Evil”
and not allow for censorship.
Larry and Sergey would end up getting their
way and Google would leave China in 2010,
but that didn’t shake the feeling.
For the first time, Larry felt that Eric was
pulling Google in a different direction, a
direction that he didn’t want to go down.
It was clear to him that it was time for Eric
to go and for himself to take the reigns once
again.
And given that Larry now had a relatively
positive relationship with the board, thanks
to Eric, he was able to lobby for himself
to become CEO once again.
Eric who was quickly approaching 60 didn’t
really resist.
He’d been there for nearly 10 years and
it felt like a natural time to move on.
So, he would leave of with the remark, “I
believe Larry is ready, I'm sure he'll do
a fantastic job.”
And with that, Larry was CEO once again, but
the truth was that he wasn’t really ready.
He instantly turned back to his old tendencies,
but this time he had a different target.
He felt that the biggest limiter for Google
wasn’t managers, but rather shareholders.
While he may very well have been right, let’s
just say it’s not a great idea to make shareholders
an enemy as public CEO.
Larry would learn this the hard way, and he
would only last a few years as CEO.
Pretty soon, he would promote Sundar Pichai
to CEO leading us to the modern day Google.
ERIC’S LEGACY:
At the end of the day, Larry and Sergey truly
are the visionaries behind Google, but their
visions would have never materialized if it
wasn’t for Eric.
The reality was that while Larry and Sergey
were brilliant engineers and forward thinkers,
they just weren’t all that great businessmen.
And if it wasn’t clear the first time around,
it was definitely clear the second time around.
They needed someone to focus and execute on
their ideas and that’s exactly what Eric
did.
To be honest, Eric still had a few good years
in him at Google, but I suppose it all worked
out fine anyway.
All of the stock that Eric earned during his
tenure made him the 72nd richest person in
the world with a net worth of $21 billion.
But, that’s arguably the smallest part of
his legacy.
Did you know about Eric Schmidt?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you would like to see
more videos about untold business legends.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.